es sind manchmal kleinigkeiten die
erfolg von misserfolg trennen so ist es
auch in der forschung man denke nur an
die erfindung der haft etikett jetzt ist
genau so etwas einem 17 jährigen briten
fakt ist er hat nur etwas anders gemacht
und schon konnte er einen fehler der
nager aufspüren wie es gemacht hat jetzt
wirklich zum science fiction herzlich
willkommen timothy peake war der erste
britische aston aus an bord der
internationalen raumstation iss und der
erste astronaut im weltraum der dort
einen marathon die anfang letzten jahres
schaffte er die 42,195 kilometer auf
einem laufband in einer beachtlichen
zeit von 3 stunden und 35 minuten
parallel zum londoner marathon lauf von
seinem aufenthalt im all brachte er
daten mit auf die erde die nasa im
anschluss britischen schulen im rahmen
eines projektes institute for research
in schools also instituts für die
forschung an schulen zur verfügung
stellt an diesem projekt nahm auch die
treppen secondary school in sheffield
dort ist auch der 17 jährige mitschüler
und er entdeckte als erster in seiner
klasse die signifikanten fehler
die daten die die schüler untersuchen
sollten waren daten von strahlung
sensoren der asf alle vier sekunden
liefern sie einen netzwerk und meist
fand in diesem wagen sofort falsche
messwerte eigentlich war sogar ganz
einfach aber es dürfte eines tricks und
einer einzigen überlegung beim
durchgehender daten fielen sofort etwas
seltsames auf es gab negative vorzeichen
vor den messwerten
da die sensoren aber strahlung also
energie marken konnten sie eigentlich
nur nicht oder positive werte messen
das war schon mal schlauch von weitere
fortschritte eine mail an die nase und
beschrieb seine entdeckung die nasa war
verblüfft der fehler war bekannt aber
die experten dort gingen von wenigen
fehlmessungen im jahr aus mais entdeckte
dass sie viel öfter auftraten etwa
einmal am tag warum das so ist die nasa
forscher haben keine ahnung ein weiteres
rätsel des universums oder einfach ein
technischer fehler davon dienen aber
jedenfalls bisher aus jetzt haben sie
mal bürger eingeladen ihnen bei der
erforschung zu helfen wenn das mal kein
ritterschlag für mais ist er dürfte wohl
der jüngste mitarbeiter der nasa
die leute halten mich jetzt für einen
nerd beklagte sich meist bei britischen
medien dabei war sagen krieg so einfach
dass man nur darüber lachen kann er las
die datenliste einfach von hinten und da
tauchten die fehler zuerst auf ich
find's cool apropos cool oder besser und
kohl manche von euch finden dass ich zu
sehr nach aproz bettler oder nach einem
klick auf ein video dabei würde betteln
doch ganz anders aussehen die welt und
ich mag sein doch lieber wie bisher wenn
ihr die besten videos von finck sehen
wollt dann und meditiert auch klicken es
wird sensationell und wenn ihr in
zukunft nicht verpassen wollt dann
drücken wir hier ein abo auf auge auch
darauf klicken und geht mir dann noch
einen auf die glocke und was haltet ihr
vom forschung an der schule ich kann da
nur aus eigener erfahrung sprechen durch
meine jugend forscht einnahme bin ich
für den wenige kommen also bis dann
bleibt auch daran